in this video we'll see an efficient
algorithm for training a restricted
Boltzmann machine known as contrastive
divergence so we've seen there's the
post machine how it defines the
distribution over X and it's hidden
layer H we've seen that we could also
write down P of X using the free
energies and we've looked at how exactly
it tries to model and increase
probability for certain values of the
input vector let's actually see how we
can actually train the restricted
Boltzmann machine on some training data
in order to obtain a restricted
Boltzmann machine that models well that
data and assigns high probability to it
so like we've seen before we'll treat
this problem of training as an empirical
Muniz asian problem we'll do without the
regularization here and just try to
minimize the average loss where the loss
is going to be the most natural thing
here to do which is to use the negative
log probability as our loss for this
model and so what we'd like to do is
optimize this average negative log
probability of the training data using
an optimization procedure in particular
we'd like to use to cast a gradient
descent because works well and scales
well to large data sets and so it means
that to achieve this I need the partial
derivative of any parameter theta of my
loss now if I make the derivation and
write down the expression for it it
actually has a an expression which looks
kind of similar to other things we've
seen before in terms of partial
derivatives of parameters for neural
networks we have again a difference of
two terms one which depends on the
observation and another one which
depends on more explicitly only on the
model and so this partial derivative is
going to be the expec expectation over
what we never see which is the hidden
layer value of the partial derivative of
the energy with respect to my parameter
given my observation so and expect
partial derivative we have to need an
expectation because H we never know what
its value is
and so it's the expectation of this
partial derivative condition on the
observation and then we subtract that
the expectation over H and I and now
also X of the again the partial
derivitive the energy function with
respect to our parameter but notice now
we do an expectation over X as well and
this is an expectation according to our
model so under our models distribution
so we often refer to that part computing
this part of the gradient as the
positive phase and this the negative
phase for obvious reasons and but now
the problem is that this part here is
actually hard to compute it's generally
intractable and the reason is that we
have to make an exponential sum over
both H and X and so perhaps you'll be
convinced that if I give you a value of
the visible layer so if I give you an
observation X then summing over H is
actually something that's tractable to
do for this partial derivative in
particular for the RB m and E we can
again leverage the fact that we get an
expression of nested ik nested sums over
something that factorizes with respect
to each hidden unit and then we can
actually write this down into an
expression that's linear in the number
of hidden units so we'll see that more
and more details later in this video but
now if you have to do is sum over both X
and H now this becomes intractable and
so we'll have to approximate that term
somehow in order to perform stochastic
gradient descent efficiently so to
address this problem
Jeff fintan in 2002 proposed the
contrastive divergence learning
algorithm so there's some theory for
what this is actually doing I'm not
going to go over that I'm just going to
describe what the algorithm is and the
more intuitive terms and
try to give more intuition for why it
should actually work so really the idea
is to try to do without this double
expectation and instead estimated so
there are really three main components
to contrastive divergence the first idea
is that the expectation over X and H in
the negative phase will actually replace
it by a point estimate at a single
observation X still so the expectation
over X we'll replace it by a point
estimate at X still because if you have
that point estimate if we give me a
value of the visible layer then I can do
the expectation over H and then get an
estimate of the double expectation so
that's just really saying we'll do
multicolor estimate of the expectation
with a single data point then we'll we
need to obtain that X tilt somehow and
ideally we like to sample from the true
distribution not the true distribution
but our model distribution and then
we'll do this by
Gibbs sampling so remember that Gibbs
sampling corresponds to sampling each
variable in my model given the others
and specifically for a restricted
Boltzmann machine performing that
sampling is actually quite as efficient
because conditioned on one layer all the
other elements in the other layer are
independent then I can sample all the
values in one layer in parallel given
the value of the opposite layer and then
alternate between each layer like this
and so this is actually very efficient
to do in practice and then the third
idea which is perhaps the most important
contribution behind contrasted
divergence is to perform Gibbs sampling
but by starting our sampling at a state
where the visible layer is set to the
training example for which I'm trying to
compute the gradient and do an update
and so instead of starting like we
usually do in Gibbs sampling at the
configuration of my my layers my random
variables that is sample
perhaps uniformly and just randomly
according to some initial distribution
I'll actually use the value of the
training observation for the value of
the visible layer when I'm performing
Gibbs sampling and the other thing is
that I'm not actually going to do Gibbs
sampling for long I'm actually going to
do it for one two or just a few
iterations and as we'll see this
actually works well in practice so to
illustrate this process more visually so
there's air in my figure there's below
the same circle here so what we'll do is
that at training time for a given
training example I'll take the value of
the input vector X and I'll set it as my
value for my visible layer then I'll
sample all the hidden units conditioned
on observing this particular value of
the visible layer this training example
so out sampled from P of H given that X
is equal to X T in this case here just a
note on performing that sampling so each
neuron condition independent so they
each a Bernoulli for which I can compute
what's the probability for that
Bernoulli random variable that hidden
unit being called to 1 given X now to
obtain a sample from a Bernoulli with
that probability of being equal to 1
what I can do is just sample from a
uniform distribution between 0 and 1 and
then if that value that uniform value
that I sample is actually sorry it
should be the other way around so if
this value is greater than so greater
than the value the probability is
greater than the value of sample from my
uniform then I'm gonna set the that I'm
going to set the hidden layer layer unit
DG hidden layer the unit to 1 and
otherwise I'm gonna set it to 0 so in
other words the value of the hidden unit
is going to be the identity function of
whether the probability
the hidden unit is greater than a random
sample from a uniform between 0 & 1 so
we can see that this will be equal to 1
with a probability of this value because
the mass of a uniformly distributed
random variable between 0 and this value
is going to be exactly because it's
uniform it's going to be P of H equal to
1 given X so so indeed the property that
this is 1 is going to be P of HD equal 1
given X okay so now I've taken my
training sample I've sampled each of the
hidden units conditionally conditioned
on the visible layer taking that value
and then I'm going to reconstruct a
visible layer by sampling from P of X
given the current value of my hidden
layer so I could call this a x1 and then
I'm going to do that for K step so I'm
going to take X 1 and then sample a new
value of the hidden there given my
previously sample value of the visible
layer I'm going to alternate like this
performing Gibbs sampling for K steps
and now this last value after I've done
my K steps is going to be the negative
sample X tilde X still we often refer to
it as a negative sample which is used to
estimate the negative phase part of the
gradient and so I'm going to use that as
my negative sample to perform my point
estimates of the expectation over X okay
so visually what does this look like so
I get a training example and in the
positive phase I had to estimate this
conditional expectation to sample if I
imagine I actually don't perform that
expectation I just sample and H given
this XT and I'll call that H till T and
I've also performed K steps of Gibbs
sampling to have an X tilde and
similarly to perform that expect
estimated at X still and H still where H
tilled would be sample based on the
conditional distribution of the hidden
layer given that X is equal to X still
so that I get these two pairs and if I
look at the gradient descent procedure
what it's telling me is that I should
decrease the energy at the up training
observation and I should increase it at
the sample value X still and its
associated hidden layer because low
energy means high probability then this
means that I'm going to increase really
the probability of observing XT when
it's in a layer and I'm going to
decrease at the same time the
probability that X still is going to be
observed under my models distribution
and so if my training example
correspondent two images of digits then
I'd be increasing the probability of
observing this particular digit here
under my model and then say initially my
restricted Boltzmann machine is randomly
initialized so it essentially
corresponds to a uniform distribution
over binary vectors then initially one
I'm going to sample is really going to
look like noise essentially it's going
to look like something like this and so
what I'll be doing is then making the
probability of sampling something like
this from my model much smaller and then
I'll continue iterating like this so
next time around it'll be less likely
that X still would look like a random
image and the sample value for X still
are gonna be looking more and more like
actual training examples because I keep
pushing down the probability of anything
that doesn't look like a digit and so we
can see that as we keep sampling like
this then eventually the gradient should
become smaller because the value of XT
is gonna be more more similar to the
sample value of X still and so intuitive
ly this algorithm what it's doing is
that it's increasing the energy sorry
decreasing the energy of things that
look like what's in the training set
while increasing the energy of things
that are as
loosen a door sample by the model and we
keep doing this until the model fits out
or generates observations that are very
similar to what's in the model in other
words it's become a good model of our
dataset